la ville de marine cas dans le donbass
ravagé par les bombardements
ici la milice de dos nièce qu pro russes
avancent petit à petit un correspondant
d'un média chinois a pu les suivre et
s'approcher des lance-roquettes russe
qui tire en continu
marine cas est complètement déserté par
les civils si déplacée est devenu très
dangereux les tirs sont quasi permanents
et des dizaines de mines sont éparpillés
dans la zone
au sol les soldats pro russes retrouvent
du matériel militaire abandonnée ils
disent contrôler désormais un ancien
poste de commandement et craignant
autour de deux nièces qu la bataille
pour le dombass ne fait peut-être que
commencer